a good place is one of the smartest
television shows in memory it's so good
it is so good it is like literally one
of my favorite shows and I love that
it's so smart and it's about ethics
about morality it's also hilarious and
inventive it's such a good show and I
know that you guys are intentionally
bringing it to a close this season which
I imagine has to be very tough because
the show's doing great it's just I guess
Mike Schur decided this would be a good
place for it to stop it was my cool I
[Laughter]
know he did because he's got the most
integrity in the world and he just knew
where the story was gonna end and we
filmed it and you're gonna cry so much
and Manny said after he filmed the
finale he had to immediately go and
phone his parents which kind of gives
you an idea
I also found his parents after I'll give
up their number at the end we can all
call but it was incredibly emotional and
we have such amazing guest stars and we
wrapped it up perfectly and I don't know
how I'm ever gonna recover from this
incredible show it's the best thing that
ever happened to me and Ted Danson is
such an incredible man and I can't
believe I thought he's a lovely person
yeah he had us over to his house yeah I
heard about this he had you over to his
house for a sleepover yes now let me
first of all say he had a lot of people
over for a sleepover well we know what
didn't happen
anywho you posted a photo of this is you
and a bunch of people from the show that
been morning the next morning just
hanging out at Ted Danson's house my
boyfriend has me in a headlock Oh ginger
really yeah you went for a ginger rusty
window big weirdo that sounds like an
awful con yeah yeah what do you want it
rusty weird is not waking off a ghost
very wedding dowry
yeah yeah God oh you think this is wrong
No
I what I'm saying is you keep taking us
to those places I never not play okay
[Laughter]
I'm Mary Steenburgen cooked us they
cooked us breakfast the following
morning Mary Steenburgen eager but she
made us a frittata with her own
Hollywood hands and then we addressed
again and then we went home yeah
[Applause]
symmetry you had a book out